community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners findlay automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
advancing childhood literacy is the goal
of a local nonprofit that's delivered
more than six and a half million books
to kids in our community over the last
20 years joining us to talk more about
spread the word nevada we have our good
friend tyler corder who of course is the
cfo of findlay automotive group and chad
levitt who is the board chair of spread
the word gentleman thank you both for
joining us it's great to be here it is
exciting to see that spread the word
nevada has been around for more than 20
years now and has served so many kids i
think almost 750 000 kids just an
awesome charity and you know we're
involved in a lot of charities this one
we're involved with a little bit more
than than some others
and as you said they they support
childhood literacy by providing books to
kids in low income areas
and so my right hand man our chief
accounting officer over at findlay
automotive group is chad levitt who is
also the board president at uh spread
the word nevada so i wanted to bring
chad on let's talk a little bit about
what they do well and chad you guys have
done some great things for spread the
word including donating just last year
was i think a car or a vehicle for them
to use yeah we're able to be one of the
partners to donate a big box truck that
is used to distribute the books to each
of the 65 locations that we have in the
schools
and we take gently used books and
distribute them
throughout different programs and it was
imperative that we got a new vehicle and
so finley partnered with a couple other
great
foundations and companies in the in the
market and we're able to put that on the
road how great is that and you get to
meet the kids who are enjoying these
books and now it's 20 years later some
of these kids have gone through college
and their doctors or lawyers are working
in the community that has to be very
fulfilling for both of you absolutely
yeah yeah so and and it also one of the
good things we like about it is it
provides volunteer opportunities for our
employees that we go out we do a thing
called breakfast with books at whitney
elementary where we go out and have
breakfast with kids and hand out books
we also host uh uh volunteer events
where we clean the books and get them
all ready for the donation so it's you
know it's helping the kids but it's also
a good volunteer opportunity for our
people um but so it's it already all the
way around it's a good thing and it's
great because it culminates at least all
the fundraising efforts with a gala
every year and chad you got one coming
up pretty soon yeah march 19th we're
really excited about it it's going to be
actually at the new resorts world so
that'll be the first time that we get to
host something there and it's going to
be a beautiful event it's sponsored by
finley toyota with title sponsors so
we're excited about being able to be
there and support and
show off
spread the word at that new building and
tyler if people can't make it to that
gala what are some ways they can help
well if you go on and just find the
website for spread the word nevada
you'll find opportunities there
obviously donations are a big thing but
there's also volunteer opportunities and
and so if you just go to spread the word
nevada's website find all that
information right there we'd love to
have people get involved great tyler
chad thank you both for your work and
for being here today uh and we want to
thank findlay automotive group for
sponsoring this segment the 19th annual
storybook gala is happening at resorts
world if you want more information you
can go to their website we'll have a
link on it a link to it i should say on
ours or you can just go straight to it
spreadthewordnevada.org